[Music]
trillions of bacteria viruses and fungi
live on or inside of us
and maintaining a good balanced
relationship with them is to our
advantage together they form the gut
microbiome a rich ecosystem that
performs a variety of functions in our
bodies
the bacteria in our guts can break down
food the body can't digest produce
important nutrients regulate the immune
system and protect against harmful germs
we don't yet have the blueprint for
exactly which good bacteria a robust gut
needs
but we do know that it's important for a
healthy microbiome to have a variety of
bacterial species many factors affect
our microbiomes including our
environment medications like antibiotics
and even whether we were delivered by
c-section or not
diet 2 is emerging as one of the leading
influences on the health of our guts
and while we can't control all these
factors we can manipulate the balance of
our microbes by paying attention to what
we eat
dietary fiber from foods like fruits
vegetables nuts legumes and whole grains
is the best fuel for gut bacteria
when bacteria digest fiber they produce
short chain fatty acids that nourish the
gut barrier
improve immune function
and can help prevent inflammation which
reduces the risk of cancer
and the more fiber you ingest the more
fiber-digesting bacteria colonize your
gut
in a recent study scientists exchanged
the regular high fiber diets of a group
of rural south africans with the
high-fat meat-heavy diets of a group of
african-americans
after just two weeks on the high fat low
fiber western style diet the rural
african group showed increased
inflammation of the colon as well as a
decrease of butyrate
that's a short chain fatty acid thought
to lower risk of colon cancer meanwhile
the group that switched to a high fiber
low-fat diet had the opposite result
so what goes wrong with our gut bacteria
when we eat low fiber processed foods
lower fiber means less fuel for the gut
bacteria essentially starving them until
they die off
this results in less diversity and
hungry bacteria
in fact some can even start to feed on
the mucous lining
we also know that specific foods can
affect gut bacteria
in one recent microbiome study
scientists found that fruits vegetables
tea coffee red wine and dark chocolate
were correlated with increased bacterial
diversity
these foods contain polyphenols which
are naturally occurring antioxidant
compounds
on the other hand foods high in dairy
fat like whole milk and sugar-sweetened
sodas were correlated with decreased
diversity how food is prepared also
matters
minimally processed fresh foods
generally have more fiber and provide
better fuel
so lightly steamed sauteed or raw
vegetables are typically more beneficial
than fried dishes
there are also ways of preparing food
that can actually introduce good
bacteria also known as probiotics into
your gut
fermented foods are teeming with helpful
probiotic bacteria like lactobacillus
and bifidobacteria
originally used as a way of preserving
foods before the invention of
refrigeration
fermentation remains a traditional
practice all over the world foods like
kimchi sauerkraut tempeh and kombucha
provide variety and vitality to our
diets
yogurt is another fermented food that
can introduce helpful bacteria into our
guts that doesn't necessarily mean that
all yogurt is good for us though
brands with too much sugar and not
enough bacteria may not actually help
these are just general guidelines more
research is needed before we fully
understand exactly how any of these
foods interact with our microbiomes
we see positive correlations but the
insides of our guts are difficult places
to make direct observations
for instance we don't currently know
whether these foods are directly
responsible for the changes in diversity
or if something more complicated is
happening
while we're only beginning to explore
the vast wilderness inside our guts we
already have a glimpse of how crucial
our microbiomes are for digestive health
the great news is we have the power to
fire up the bacteria in our bellies
fill up on fibers fresh and fermented
foods and you can trust your gut to keep
you going strong
[Music]
you